well the hearing wrapped up earlier
earlier tonight and I did watch the
entire thing and I feel exhausted after
watching it I can only imagine how Brett
Kavanaugh feels considering he was the
one on the grill as it were now what
I'll say is and I'll echo what what what
Brett Kavanaugh said in his in his
stirring and compelling an incredible
opening speech and also what some
Republicans said and what and what
Lindsey Graham said and I feel like at
the very beginning I have to begin by
retracting every negative comment I've
ever made about Lindsey Graham and
unfortunately it's quite a lot of
retracting because I've made a lot of
negative comments about it but he lined
if you haven't watched that yet go and
and there are plenty of clips of it
online but he during during Cavanaugh's
hearing he we'll get to that in a minute
but he he jumped in and launched into
one of the maybe the greatest rant by a
politician I've ever seen but I want to
echo what he said and say that the whole
thing was a sham and a circus and a
charade an utter disgrace I think the
entire thing this whole the last two
weeks culminating in this in this
hearing I think it all adds up to
certainly the lowest point in modern
American political history maybe the
lowest point in American political
history period he was just it's the kind
of thing where you watch it and you say
to yourself well there's really no
healing this country is there if this is
how far we've fallen and if you have one
side of the political aisle that this is
how evil they are and they have just so
completely detached themselves from any
semblance of morality integrity honesty
basic human decency and they will do
literally anything literally anything to
destroy the people who come against them
if that's where we are then and more
than that more concerning that if we
have half of the country about who could
watch something like that you know can
sit down and watch all of that and see
what's happened over the last two weeks
see all of that and say yeah this is
fair this is right this is how it should
be those kinds of people I just what
they're living in a different universe
from many and frankly you know watching
the hearing I all I kept thinking to
myself is not watching these Democrats
and their and their despicable
disgraceful performance all I could
think of I I am ashamed to share a
country with these people I wish that I
did not have to share a country with
them and the really incredible thing is
that like I said I watched all eight
hours of it so this was eight hours
about I think if I'm doing method but
eight hours of a hearing which was
ostensibly to investigate and talk about
a sexual assault allegation but the
incredible thing is that in eight hours
and all of the many questions that were
asked almost none of the questions were
actually about the sexual assault itself
almost none of them christine ford was
up there and of course the democrats
didn't ask her any questions just every
time they had a chance they they took
the opportunity to commend her on her
bravery and then do a little campaign
speech and the republicans outsourced
their questioning to a to a to a sex
crimes prosecutor who oddly enough
showed little interest in talking about
the alleged sex crime and figuring out
whether or not it actually happened
which or at least whether or not Brett
Kavanaugh was the one who committed it
which is why she was there instead she
spent a lot of time talking about
Christine Ford's travel arrangements and
just all kinds of questions about what
what she was doing in the last three
months instead of get home homing in on
what was gone what happened or didn't
happen during the time in question in
1982 or whenever that's you know events
supposedly occurred now so at the
beginning this was it was to start with
with with Christine Ford it was a
disaster for the Republicans in their
decision their decision not only to
outsource it to this woman who I'm sure
is very good at her job
but she just was not doing what she
needed to do in this situation but not
only that but the format that they set
up which was the prosecutor could
develop a line of questioning and then
that line of questioning would be
punctuated every five minutes by a
campaign speech from a Democrat it was
just uh it was a total disaster going
through it one by one let's talk about
four then we'll talk about cab mom now
Ford she came across as competent and
credible her performance was in parts
stirring it was emotionally involving
right and so if we're evaluating her
testimony rationally and objectively now
for evaluating her testimony emotionally
then you went away from it thinking well
Brett Kavanaugh was guilty as hell until
he got up there and then he was
emotional too but we'll get that in a
second if you're evaluating it
rationally and objectively however her
testimony was insufficient and the
entire presentation from the Democrats
was grossly insufficient now Democrats
know that most Americans do not evaluate
things rationally objectively but in
fact evaluate things emotionally which
is why after Christine Ford's testimony
Democrats were feeling really good
because they knew that didn't matter
there were no facts no evidence nothing
that didn't matter they had a motion on
their side well then Brett Kavanaugh
went in there and he had some emotion of
his own to show but through her opening
statement and her interactions with the
Democrat senators and a little bit with
her interactions with the with the
prosecutor that was hired by Republicans
although like I said she didn't really
focus at all on the actual subject but
Christine Ford she retold basically the
same story we already read in the
Washington Post a little additional
information was provided
she says she remembers with 100%
certainty that Brett Kavanaugh assaulted
her she also remembers and was given the
opportunity to repeat by Democrats they
went back to this line several times
they went back to it but she said she
remembers the laughter of Kavanaugh and
Mark judge now there's a reason by the
way she said she remembers the
the Brett Kavanaugh she remembers the
laughter they're laughing while they
were doing she also remembers the
stairwell and she says she remembers
that the house was sparsely furnished
and those are really the only details
that she remembers Democrats kept going
back to the laughter they wanted her to
keep bringing it up because that's just
it's an emotional appeal whether it's
true or not whether Brett Kavanaugh was
in there laughing or not just the image
of two guys laughing as a sexual assault
a girl it's a very disturbing image
whether or not it's a true image of
course Democrats still care about that
whatsoever it's just a disturbing image
and they want you to have that
disturbing image in your head but all of
those details she remembers and she
remembers all those details apparently
with with absolute certainty but the
really important detail she doesn't
they're after her testimony a number of
enormous questions still remained like
number one when did this happen
number two where did it happen number
three how did she get to the place where
it happened number four how did she get
home number five who else was there
now that the the the last two questions
are very important and the question
about and I'm just you know saying to my
wife was we were watching this hearing
and I was a guy kept saying why the
prosecutor she needs to come back and
focus on this for a minute the fourth
question about how did she get home it's
a very important question she said she
didn't have her driver's license at the
time her she was 15 years old she says
okay and the driving age was was 16 and
she's sure that she didn't have a
driver's license all right well
according to her she rushed out of the
house after she had just been assaulted
by two boys
she lived some miles from the country
club where this happened and according
to a map that was presented by the
prosecutor I'm blanking on her name or I
would use her name Mitchell I think
according to a map presented by Mitchell
she was probably about six to eight
miles or so from the from the country
club so that means that somebody drove
her home okay
so just think about this for a second
you've got a 15 year old girl now it
this is let's just go with Christine
Ford's version of events here for men
you've got a 15 year old girl who was
just assaulted at a party she said she
thought she was going to die she thought
they were going to rape her she was
traumatized she runs out of the house
fearing for her life we imagine she's
probably crying now she leaves
so she shoots she exits the door and
then apparently that's what her memory
cuts off right there she remembers all
of that vividly soon as she acts exits
the door no memory has no memory but
there's this whole other part where
somebody she would have had to somehow
call somebody or maybe she had a
prearranged for someone a meet her I
don't know but somehow she communicated
with somebody right after this happened
and she got in their car moments after
just being sexually assaulted moments
after fearing that she was about to be
killed by two boys who were trying to
rape her as a 15 year old girl she gets
into the car and she drives home this
person whoever that person is it's an
extremely crucial witness because they
can testify to her demeanor her mental
state I mean what was she like when you
picked her up because if she was
perfectly normal and bubbly and happy
and everything was fine then it's just
impossible to believe that she was just
moments ago sexually assaulted and she
thought almost killed but if she was
crying if she was disturbed if she was
you know something was seriously wrong
well that's very compelling evidence yet
she can't tell us who picked her up she
can't give us that name so it's
Democrats were pushing a Brett Kavanaugh
when he was up there and they were
pushing you know they wanted to know
about this mark a judge character why
isn't he testified nobody ever pressed
Christine Ford who picked you up moments
after you were supposedly sexually
assaulted who was it and can we speak to
them that question incredibly was never
asked
the point was not visited at all and it
to me look I'm sorry I just I don't
believe that Christine for doesn't
remember driving home from a sexual
assault I just don't believe I I have
plenty people have said that sexual
assault when that happens your memory
can be spotty so I'll defer to the
people that have gone through that they
say your memory can be spotty fine but
but you're telling me that there's just
a total cutoff right there you remember
everything vividly the stairwell the
furnishing the laughter the bathroom you
remember the layout of the house you
remember all of that you remember
rushing out of the house then you get
out and you're inside the house you have
no recollection whatsoever of what
happened as soon as you were outside the
door I just don't believe that I feel
like she's omitting something for some
reason and we should know what that
reason is and what's being omitted and
the prosecutor should have asked her she
should have said miss miss mrs. Florrick
what's your so you you what rut ran out
of the house you don't remember what
happened next what is your next memory
what's the next thing you remember right
after that do you remember something
from that night do you remember
something from a week later I mean what
the question was never asking it was an
important question the other question
that we still don't have an answer to
it's very important is is what about all
the other people at the party because we
know that the witnesses that she named
have denied it have refuted her
allegations have said that they have no
memory of it or in fact the party never
occurred so we need to know about that
but we also need to know and again this
was not focused on or honed in on the
prosecutor Mitchell alluded to it but
you're at a party you say it's a small
quiet gathering and in fact judge and
Cavanaugh according to you are the only
ones there that are completely plastered
right just a few people well then you
would say that you were sexually
assaulted in a room
upstairs what were the other people
doing during this time did they not hear
the racket
did they not wonder where these three
people went your friends that were there
did they wonder why you disappeared into
a bedroom with two drunk boys they
didn't ask you about it in school the
next day didn't ask you about it when
you came downstairs they said so three
people disappear into a bedroom at this
disquiet gathering the two boys emerge
the girl runs out of the house nobody
ever asks her about it ever and says
what happened to you again it's an
unanswered question so the effect was
you know three hours of testimony from
from Christine Ford and we got no closer
to the truth now Cavanaugh on an
emotional level Cavanaugh behaved
exactly as an innocent man would and
should behave after being dragged
through the mud and slandered by
political con artists I was very worried
after watching the Fox interview I was
critical of him and I said that you know
his performance just didn't cut it there
he was way too reserved it was what he's
holding himself back way too much he was
not acting like a person should act if
they're innocent
and have been accused of this and are
being the victor families are being
victimized by coordinated smear campaign
and their whole lives and their families
everything's ruined
he wasn't acting like like that in the
Fox interview well at the at the hearing
he acted like that he came out swinging
he was angry defiant indignant he was on
the offensive he wasn't suffering the
Democrat fools
he didn't sit back politely while they
continued with their character
assassination he didn't do that and it
was great it was exactly what it needed
to be and I thought look emotionally you
see Christine Ford and you're just a
good and evaluating emotionally without
any biases and you see that you're okay
well you sympathize with her well then
you see you see Ford are you see
Cavanaugh how can you not sympathize
with him man was emotional angry I got
choked up at various different points
talking about his daughter and how this
is affected her talking about his
parents talking about how his life has
been affected it just was it came across
extremely authentic and sincere which
was the most important thing
and in my view you know even better than
then Cavanaugh is opening statement
which was gripping but I really liked
with a contentious and almost flippant
way that he handled the embarrassing
lines of questions from Democrats
because that's exactly how an innocent
man would act and should act when it
when he would involve our yearbook
scribblings and inside jokes from his
teenage years are being used to paint
them as a serial gang rapists I mean the
Democrats were up there asking about you
know fart jokes that he made in high
school and going back a time and time
again asking Judge Cavanaugh did you
drink beer yes I did
well yes but did you drink beer yes I
did well but you drank beer yes I mean
you were consuming beer in high school
were you not consuming beer yes I did
well but look stop for a minute what
about beer did you consume that and just
over and over and over again they spent
three hours asking about beer jokes that
he made listen if you can be penalized
legally for inside jokes that you have
with your friends as a 17 year old boy
well then I'm gonna be on death row okay
if the the content of your inside jokes
and of your you know general demeanor as
a 17 year old boy can be held against
you then then I'm in a lot of trouble I
think I think a lot of I think a lot of
guys are in trouble because teenage boys
can tend to be vulgar yes sometimes they
can drink beer they can you know that's
just how they are but the really
important thing is
with the evidence you know Ford had no
material evidence no witnesses she could
provide very few details kavanah on the
other hand had material evidence in the
form of his 1982 calendars he had
witnesses to refute the allegations
against him he could provide many
details there's a stark contrast between
Christine Ford who couldn't say yet
didn't know it I mean she couldn't even
recount information and details from
conversations she had in the last three
months meanwhile Brett Kavanaugh was
like okay well this is where I was I can
tell you where I was on like July 2nd
1982 and he had his calendar and you can
do I mean he was very organized in that
way you know they say that you can't
prove a negative
you can't a man cannot prove that he
didn't do something especially he can't
prove that he didn't do something 35
years ago well Brett Kavanaugh came
about as close to clearing that hurdle
as any person possibly ever could
okay so we're left with two options okay
either one of these people cabin our
Ford our sociopathic Liars who can cry
on command and summon very convincing
but fake emotions on live television so
there's social death of liars and
they're great great actors both of those
things that's one option one of those
you know one option is that one of the
two of them is that or they're both
telling basically the truth as they see
it okay now that's if the second option
is is is correct that means that
Christine Ford is mistaken it means that
or it could mean that she's embellishing
slightly I mean there could be there
could be some slight embellishments and
so forth on both ends so Christine Ford
could be a Bella Shing maybe Brett
Kavanaugh could be I mean he kept being
who's cross-examined about how much beer
he drank he was obviously trying to
downplay that but really who cares how
much beer you drank anyway so but that's
that's basically the option you have is
either one of them is totally lying
or they're both basically recounting
things as they remember it and Christine
for just remembers it incorrectly or has
has these years later after having some
kind of experience with somebody she's
now kind of put Brett Kavanaugh face on
the situation which is a possibility but
if we're gonna go with the option that
one of these people is a liar which I'm
not saying that I go with that option
but if you do I don't see how you can
hang the liar label on the guy that has
all of the wet evidence and all of the
witnesses to back him up so that's it
judge Kavanagh has been run through the
gauntlet he's been subjected to the
worst smear campaign in American
political history the Democrat Party is
as I've been saying now truly truly
deeply evil with no regard for truth or
human decency whatsoever and Brett
Kavanaugh has withstood that he's still
standing and if anybody has ever earned
a job ever I think he has earned this
job on the Supreme Court then he needs
to be confirmed that's my that's my
Rapid Reaction take I'll talk to you
guys tomorrow